You have the exams back,
I'll have a good answer key for you soon.
That currently the answer key just has which slides of the presentation where
the subject of each uh,
question,
uh,
may be good news that we're moving onto a new topic.
Okay,
so it's spectroscopy and it start last time we started talking about IRR
spectroscopy where the general idea you remember is that molecules vibrate.
If they change their dipole moment as they vibrate,
they can interact with light.
That is the electric vector of light can,
can cause them to vibrate at a higher amplitude,
but always at the same frequency.
And it's important as in pushing a child on a swing that you push at the right
time.
If you just go Wang,
Wang,
Wang with some little kids do,
uh,
the person won't go on the swing.
You have to push just when it's when they're coming back.
So you have to,
the frequency of the light has to be exactly the same as the natural frequency
with which the molecule vibrates.
But the molecule can vibrate in many ways.
And these are called normal modes.
And we were beginning to illustrate those last time.
Uh,
we illustrated it with butane,
but show the spectrum of octane,
which has the same features.
And last time we saw that there were lots of degrees of freedom,
even in butane,
many more in octane there,
36 normal modes there,
but 72 in octane.
And we looked at what some of them were,
that that one was the,
um,
was the coordinated stretching of the ch bonds as indeed,
uh,
with the field pushing up and down.
And the next one,
that blue one,
there are one of those peaks is the hydrogens moving,
coordinated Lee in and out in a normal mode where all vibrate at exactly the
same frequency.
And that's the frequency of that light.
And that one notice the electric vector goes in and out of the board rather than
up and down.
Okay.
So those were ch stretches.
There are other ch stretches like this one,
which are a sort of a briefing of the hydrogens,
which don't change the dipole moment,
therefore,
light has no handle on it and that doesn't appear in the,
uh,
in the,
IRR spectrum.
Okay.
There is another kind of spectroscopy called Raman spectroscopy which can see
that kind of vibration and in fact of the 10 ch stretches that combine to give
10 normal modes involving ch stretching.
Half of them have no handle and you can't see them in the eye are,
but we can go on to other peaks now.
Those were ch stretching at very high frequency.
Now we're at at high low frequency,
right?
The high end of the low frequency peaks and that particular peak is this motion
of the hydrogens.
What's here?
If you had to give that kind of,
if you had the name,
that kind of emotion of a ch two group that you see in this one,
what would you call it?
Exactly?
It scissors.
Okay.
Then this one,
oops,
I went too far.
Oops,
sorry.
There we go.
Notice the motion is almost entirely in the methyl groups at the end,
not within the chain.
It's a bending.
It's in fact much similar to the scissors motion of the ch two groups,
but this one is called something else.
Could you give it a fanciful name of what one methyl group is doing?
It's called the umbrella mode.
Okay.
Uh,
this little peak here turns out to be this motion.
See how they're wagging back and forth.
And he'd given ch two is going like this.
Oh,
sorry.
There we go.
Okay.
That's the way lag.
And this last beat down here is this one.
Yeah.
So the ch are going like this.
All right?
And that's the rocking mode.
So bear in mind that were,
that were illustrated with butane,
but showing octane,
but they have these same motions.
I've obviously,
octane has those same motions as as uh,
uh,
butane does.
And they're all coordinated together at the same frequency.
So what's a normal mode?
And obviously the ones that appear in the spectrum are,
I are active.
So now how about functional groups?
Here we were looking just at a saturated alkane.
What IRR is especially good for is identifying functional groups.
So that was octane.
And here's oc Tine.
Incidentally,
what does I mean is a suffix
means a triple bond and methyl acetylene is methyl on a triple bond,
not nothing.
A lot of double bonds that gave some people problems on the exam.
Okay.
So most of the peaks are the same fight.
In fact,
there's One p here,
that one which is almost precisely the same.
Do you remember what that one was?
And octane
that one?
Well,
we'll see just a second.
And now look at that was for AWC Tine and now if we look at one arc tine,
a triple bond in a different position that the last two carbons,
then we see exactly that same peak again,
right?
So all these things,
octane,
a oc for rock tied,
one oc Tine,
all have that sharp peak that's circled.
Okay.
And it's this motion,
right?
It's that same umbrella motion.
Right?
And why is it so special?
Why is it occur at exactly the same place in all of these?
Because it has its own frequency,
a certain frequency,
different from the frequencies of the neighboring ch twos.
So it does couple with them,
right?
It's a bad energy match for that frequency with the neighbors.
So it doesn't couple very much.
So it stands alone and is the same at octane on October nine also octine as
you'll see shortly.
Uh,
okay,
so that's that one.
Now there's some other peaks here that are new,
like there's one at really high frequency,
33 15 right now.
What's that?
Here's,
here's the molecule and watch its motion.
What's mostly happening.
Okay,
and why is it different from anything you saw in octane
at higher frequency?
First,
what's moving mostly?
Are you sure
the ch bond is stretching and why is the stretching of this ch bond different
from the stretching of the bonds we saw in octane?
Why is it a different frequency so that it doesn't mix up with other things?
Right?
Bad Energy match.
It doesn't mix.
Ayesha
can't hear very well.
It's true that it's in the plane.
In fact,
it's in the line.
In this case right there,
all those items except for three hydrogens are on a line.
But what's special about that ch bond is compared to others.
We've,
we've seen things special about an acetylene ch bond before in its chemistry.
S P hybridized.
Remember it's acidic.
It's unusually acidic.
25 of his,
it's PKA because it's a ch bond.
So it's much stronger than the others,
right?
So it's at higher frequency,
As you'd expect for a stronger spring.
Okay.
Now at the other end of the spectrum,
there's this really strong peak at 630 and that's this motion.
It's bending the hydrogen up and down,
right?
Bending that ch bond.
And that turns out to be much easier than bending bonds that are normally
hybridized.
Okay?
So that's that bending.
So that's characteristic of having an acetylene in the molecule.
If it's a terminal acetylene at the end of the chain that you,
uh,
you'll have these,
if it's not at the end of the chain,
then you don't have this kind of ch.
Okay.
Now what's this peak here at 2120.
Give me some thoughts about what that might be.
What kind of peaks come at the far left of the spectrum but very high frequency?
Ch Ch is because the HSO light,
right?
And then when you get bendings of Chs or stretching's of cc,
those come in the right half of the spectrum.
So this particular peak at 2120 is in,
what's a window usually?
Usually there's nothing.
There must be something really special that vibrates at that frequency.
And the idea of what could make something,
it's not an,
it's not a ch bond.
It must be a CC bond,
but it's a very special cc bonds.
What is it that would vibrate it?
Very high frequency.
The triple bond is three times as strong as a single bond.
So it comes at an unusually high frequency for a CC bond.
And here's its motion.
Oops.
All right,
so it's the CC bond stretching.
Okay.
Now notice that in the spectrum of four oc Tine the blue spectrum,
you don't have that peak.
Why don't you see the triple bond stretching in for rock tine?
How many carbons are there in AUC time?
Right?
There's no change in the dipole moment because it's symmetrical as you move like
that.
If it's at the end of the chain,
it's unsymmetrical,
right?
And you can see it.
But if it's the middle of the chain,
it doesn't change the dipole moment.
Okay?
So you can take it.
Tell the difference.
In two ways here between a triple bond that's at the end of the chain and a
triple bond that's in the middle of the chain.
Okay,
so there's no handle for the light,
interact with that one.
So we've seen octane,
we've seen AUC tines to AWC tines,
the four and the one.
Now let's look at Octine,
a different functional group.
So again,
most of the peaks look exactly the same as you because they have cha long chains
of ch two but it's trans for octine.
So there's a carbon carbon double bond.
Okay,
now there's this big peak at nine 67 right?
now what could that be?
Now,
here's sis that was trans for octine.
Here's sis for [inaudible] and now you see a peak at 1655 what do you suppose
that is?
Hm?
It's not not involved in an age.
It's very high frequency,
but it doesn't involve age.
Those are up around 3000 any ideas for this one?
The double bond stretching.
Now why do you see it insists for team,
but you don't see it in trans for oc team.
All right.
So that stretching is can be symmetrical,
right?
And if it's trans double bond like this,
then it truly is symmetrical,
right?
There's a center of symmetry there,
But if it sits for AWC,
tead then is you stretch the double bond and change the bonds,
changed the bonds from carbon,
the carbon,
you change the dipole moment in this direction,
not in this direction,
right?
So if you have a system like that,
then the dipole change is actually in a different direction.
Of course,
normally you major these spectra on,
on solutions.
So the PA,
so there'll be some molecules that are oriented properly,
but if you had molecules that were or fixed like in a crystal,
you could tell which way the double bonds were oriented by seeing which
direction,
uh,
the electric vector could interact with it.
Okay.
But notice that down at the low frequency and that has a big peak at seven 10,
whereas the Trans isomer had nine 67.
Now what are the,
what was the really low frequency peak in acetylene?
Remember in the one oc Tine number,
the one that was really down low,
that was the bending of the Ch.
So these are down low.
They could be bending of the CH.
Okay.
And let's just to compare,
look at,
uh,
a double bond that has three carbons on it.
So just one age that could bend out of plane and it has a peak at eight 28.
Now,
of course,
the others that don't have that extra methyl group,
our,
uh,
our CIS and trans,
but have two H's,
two h assists or two H's trans,
right?
And they'll couple as they vibrate because they're near one another,
So there's perfect energy match,
right,
of these two.
So if you have any overlap,
any coupling mechanism,
mechanical coupling,
if one can feel the other vibrating,
uh,
then you'll,
you should get to vibrations coupled vibrations.
That is,
if we look at it this way,
you have the eight 28,
which is a single age.
But if you had to have them at eight 28 and they could interact,
you'd get a higher peak and a lower peak,
which looks like what we see in a way.
But the higher peak comes in one compound and the lower peak comes in.
Another one.
Where is the second of those two peaks that got mixed together?
Okay,
we can turn it that way.
To see the analog to,
to uh,
orbital mixing.
Okay,
so let's look at pictures of these vibrations.
Okay?
At the top you see is the molecule that has just one hydrogen at the bottom.
On the left are too hight two hydrogens on the double bond trans.
And on the right there sister one another.
Now this is the vibration we're looking at out of plane vibration of the Cah.
Everybody see what I'm talking about?
It's out of played vibration to the Cah at the top.
Now at the bottom there to CHS and notice that in this vibration,
those two h is move in the same direction,
both up and both down at the same time,
right?
Why?
Why don't we,
why don't I show the one where one moves up in the other,
moves down.
Why isn't that relevant for our discussion?
Because there was no dipole moment for that one.
Right?
It cancels.
One went up,
the other went down.
Okay.
So they to be,
I are active to interact with the light.
They have to move the same direction.
Okay.
But notice this is interesting.
Uh,
so they move in the same direction to be active.
That one is at eight 28.
This one,
notice that when they both move up,
it twists the bond.
See how it twists the center of carbon bond when the two hydrogens move up,
but on the right,
so that reduces the pie overlap.
It weakens the Pi bond.
When those p orbitals don't overlap as well.
But on the right,
when they both move the same direction,
The p orbitals still points so that they overlap with one another.
So the one on the left is harder to do because it weakens the Pi bond.
It distorts the Pi Bond,
whereas the one on the right doesn't distort the Pi Bond.
So the one on the left is harder to do and it's higher frequency.
So folding preserves the pie overlap,
the harder one and the easier one,
the harder one is high frequency,
the easier one is low frequency.
So you can understand why you see only when these two vibrations mix,
why you see only one.
You only see the one where they move in parallel,
right?
And it's easier if they're like this than if they're like this where you're
twisting the bond as well.
So not only are those the high and low frequency peak handy because they
diagnose being assist or a trans double bond.
You can tell which one you have,
but also you couldn't understand what it tells you about the bonding,
why you have one that's high in the other low.
Okay?
But the real jewel in the crown of infrared spectroscopy is the carbon carbonyl
group.
Why should it be such a great group?
Why should it be so good at an infrared spectroscopy?
Why should it stand out and be something that you can really identify what kind
of carbon neo group you have first,
it absorbs very strongly.
It interacts very strongly with light.
What determines how strongly something interacts with light,
how much you can push the Adams with the electric field of light.
Luke,
you got an idea,
not just the number of electrons,
but how much the dipole moment changes when you stretch.
Right?
If the diaper,
if the electorate,
if the electrons change a lot,
when you stretch it and it becomes much more plus minus the,
that the plus minus gets separated more,
then that's a strong interaction with light.
Okay.
And the CEO is a polar bond,
so it changes much more than a ch bond does is it vibrates.
So it's going to be a very strong peak,
is not going to be one of these wimpy little peaks.
Okay.
Now why does it stand that a particular,
why does it stay on doubt in its frequency from one molecule to the next?
You don't have to worry so much about the coupling in interpreting it.
A certain ketone.
Ketone will always be very near where another key tone is,
right at the same frequency.
Why?
Because that bond is a double bond and nearby bonds,
arts double bonds.
So the nearby bonds that it can couple its vibration with have very different
frequency.
So you have very little overlap so you don't change the frequency very much when
it interacts with its neighbors.
So it stands alone and is as characteristic of a particular kind of carbon eel
and it's very strong so that you can see it in the IRS spectrum easily.
Okay,
so that's why these are so great.
The carbon eel.
So here's a key tone or a,
pardon me,
an Aldehyde acid aldehyde.
Notice how very strong a peak it is,
right?
It's got its strong and it's independent.
It doesn't mix much with its neighbors.
Okay.
Now there's a Ketone,
right?
Acetone.
Notice it's about 12 wave numbers,
lower frequency,
but that's,
that's reproducible.
The ketones would come with a little higher frequency aldehydes come in a little
lower frequency,
or pardon me,
vice versa.
So you can tell which is which.
Okay,
now here's an amid where we put a nitrogen on the carbon oxygen double bond.
Now that went to a substantially lower frequency.
1681 why should the CEO bond double bond of an amid be weak and vibrate at lower
frequency a week or spring?
Anybody got an idea of why the nitrogen would do well,
how the nitrogen would do that to the COO?
Double bond
eat.
How about you
and Pi Star?
So you've put electrons in from the nitrogen into the anti-bonding orbital of
the CEO weakening the COO bond and lowering its vibration frequency.
So there's the unshared pair,
we've mixed them with Pi Star and it gets to 1681 right.
So the CEO is weakened by resonance,
right by occupancy of the Pi Star.
Okay.
Now suppose we put look at an ester where we have an oxygen next to the carbon
eel.
Can I get some on to predict that for me?
Pokey,
what do you think?
Whereas whereas the ester going to come compared to say a ketone and the amid
the one with nitrogen.
Okay.
They'll still be resonance.
It's an unshared pair on oxygen.
Should it be as strong as that involving the nitrogen?
No.
Why?
Why should,
why should mixing of the electrons into the Pi's star be weaker for oxygen than
it is for nitrogen.
Hi Star.
Here are the electrons on the outerwear interest in at oxygen or nitrogen.
But oxygen is,
you say has a higher nuclear charge.
Lower it doesn't mix as much,
so it shouldn't lower the frequency as much as 1,681 so I think you would
predict it.
It'd be someplace between 1715 and 1681 makes sense?
Yep.
Okay.
There it is.
It's higher frequency.
1746 so there's something different.
It not only is it not as good as nitrogen,
it goes the opposite direction.
Now how about if we put a halogen on their light?
Chlorine,
right?
That's higher still 1806 it's true.
It's a,
it's electronic payer is lower,
right?
So it won't mix as much.
It won't weaken it as much as nitrogen did.
But why does it strengthen it to have a halogen there?
Okay,
so here's a different kind of resonance.
You have an unshared pair on the,
on the right,
we used an unshared pair of the adjacent datum to interact with the carbon eel.
Now we're going to use it unshared pair on the oxygen or the carbon eel to mix
with an orbital of the CX bond.
What orbital could that mix with?
It could mix with sigma star.
Okay,
so if you mix that with sigma star,
right,
then you strengthen the CEO Bob,
you get a triple bond between oxygen and carbon and and occupy sigma star.
So the appropriate resonance structure would be one with no bond to that x
group.
Of course,
that's only a,
that's not the dominant structure,
but it's one that causes the bond to get to get the CEO bond to get stronger.
So it moves to high frequency.
So we can see that that interaction is important.
And in this case,
the mixing with the Sigma Star witness,
the CEO is strengthened by resonance.
So in the case of a mid,
it was weakened by residents.
In this case,
it's strengthened by resonance.
Then that case it was a pi at or action putting electrons in pies.
Star.
In this one,
it's putting electrons in Sigma Star,
right?
And making a triple bond.
Okay.
Now how about the here,
look at this case here where we have a carbon carbon double bond.
Now we don't have the low sigma star,
right?
So we're not going to get the effect we got in the acid in the s or the acid
chloride in the Ester,
right?
And we have Pi electrons.
It could do the mixing.
Okay,
so that looks like a case where this resonance structure could be,
could be significant and it would weaken the COO double bond,
right?
But the peak is in fact that higher frequency than a ketone 1720 now why is
this?
So notice that in this case you have two double bonds are separated only by one
single bond.
So they,
they both have,
they have a better energy match these double bonds than when you had a double
bond and only single bonds in the vicinity,
right?
So now you can mix them,
you can mix them in phase and out of phase.
Okay,
so then the hears noticed that one is stretching while the other is shrinking.
It's out of phase and it's mostly a vibration of the seed double Bondo.
Right?
And that's the one that's at high frequency.
And notice it's a double peak because you have the other one when they're in
phase as well.
Okay.
Now here's the one where in phase that it's mostly a vibration to the c double
bond seat rather than the c double bond o.
But notice they're both stretching at the same time.
Okay?
So we have this situation,
we mix them,
right?
And we get 1720 and 1683
yeah.
Notice there's this peak at 1618 this is a really neat case because the doubling
that you see in that strong peak isn't what you think it is.
It's not the end phase of the out of phase.
What is the 1618
okay,
and what's the source of the doubling?
Right.
Well,
here's the spectrum of methyl vinyl,
Quito.
And that same compound with a double bond adjacent to the carbon eel measured in
Argon at 13 Kelvin.
Right?
And you can see it's got those,
that those two peaks,
1718 1680 96 but then it's got that 1623 these aren't exactly the same
frequencies we saw in the previous slide because that was measured in solution.
This is measured in an argon solid.
So there's a little influence of the neighbors on the frequency,
okay?
But if you fold ally's that at 308 nanometers for two and a half hours,
and then look at the difference between the spectrum you have now and the
spectrum you had before.
See that some peaks have gotten stronger,
they point up and those that have gotten weaker,
if you take the difference,
go down,
right?
So you'll see that peak at 1696 went down,
not up,
right?
So what does this mean?
It means that there are two different compounds there,
right?
One is becoming the other.
So the one that's been formed is getting stronger.
The one that's going away is getting weaker and appears negative when you do the
difference.
Okay?
And that's 1696 so that original Dublin we looked at is not from the same
compound.
Those two peaks,
they're from two different compounds,
right?
And but the 1696 if [inaudible] can become the 1718
So if you calculate the positions for that compound shown at the top,
you'll see the c double bond o and the c double bond.
See,
so those are the 1718 and 1623 okay,
we got that.
That's that compound.
So the in phase and the out of phase vibrations,
what's the other one?
It's this.
What's the difference?
Yeah,
it's the con formation around that central bond.
They're both planer,
but one is is likey clips and the other is like Auntie.
Okay.
So,
and if you calculate the spectrum for the one where the,
where the,
Oh,
the two double bonds or trans to one another,
you see a very strong peak at 60 and 96 and hardly anything at the low
frequency.
Why is there hardly anything at the low frequency?
Because that one,
which is mostly a CC vibration and a little bit of coupled CIO has them.
So that one tends to cancel the other.
The CEO doesn't move very much,
but it's a big dipole.
Right?
So it so it can cancel it and not the top.
They reinforce one another.
So the CDC,
the mostly cc vibration is rather strong because the CEO is helping it out.
Okay.
So one of these is called Sin Perry Planer.
It's flat Perry Planar,
but uh,
adjacent to one another and the other is anti Perry plainer.
Yeah.
Okay.
There's one more peek there and I don't know what that is.
That why do I,
it might be a combination of some other free transitions.
That's something we don't want to talk about now.
It's too complicated.
But anyhow,
here's the,
here's a picture of these vibrations.
There's the where in phase where that's the low frequency,
both stretching at the same time,
but mostly the CC,
right?
The CC is stretching nine times as much as the CEO,
but here's the actual amplitude,
right?
The actual amplitudes are very subtle for these things.
And in fact,
we talked about this a little bit last semester when we were about how when
we're doing quantum mechanics and vibration,
how much things actually move.
And here's the out of phase.
Normal mode knows mostly the COO vibration,
a little bit of cc and as one stretches the other shrinks,
right?
That's an exaggerated,
so the CEO is moving six times as much as the CC and the actual amplitude is
like that.
And if you look at lecture eight last semester,
you can see where we talked about how vibrational amplitudes are.
Okay.
So how bout I r w what we're using here,
we were talking about two things,
identifying functional groups,
characteristic peaks,
strong peaks that you can identify a particular functional group and can look
them up in tables as I suspect you did in lab already to see what functional
group would come where.
Uh,
and that's very,
that's very valuable.
We used it here more to understand how,
how strong bonds are and residents and so on.
Uh,
in the real world it can enter in a lot of cases.
One interesting case is a multibillion dollar pharmaceutical,
which uh,
which crystallizes a different crystal forms and those forms are separately
patented,
right?
The drug is called Paxil.
Okay.
So here's this,
these are taken from the patent for that compound,
paroxetine hydrochloride.
This is the anhydrous and hydrate in called form a or polymorph.
A polymorph means different shapes,
right?
Different crystals.
Okay.
Now what do we see in this spectrum?
We C,
C,
c,
c h stretching peeks over at the left and we see fingerprint regions on the
right with these all these complicated Molly,
uh,
combinations of things.
But is there anything that we can identify?
Well here,
this sort of big shoulder in here turns out to be characteristic of ammonium
ions and h plus.
Okay?
So we know it's an ammonium salt from that.
Okay.
Now what are these peaks that really high frequency,
right?
They're much higher than those that are hydrogens on a double bond.
Sp squared are indeed higher frequency than hydrogens on a single bond.
SPQ whooped,
but they're not as high as this,
right?
And what those turn out to be due to his water,
And notice that when water is hydrogen bonded like this,
you have [inaudible] that are at the end of the chain that have a very high
frequency and Ooh is that are involved in hydrogen bonding,
which are lower frequency cause they,
cause they don't just go one way,
they,
it's not so bad to move toward the other oxygen.
Okay,
so we see two peaks here,
which is interesting because this molecule is called and the anhydrate right?
But in fact it has water in it.
So that was sort of a weird thing about it.
Okay,
so here's the second form,
form B,
and again,
it has ammonium,
there's ammonium functionality and their ch and fingerprints.
And,
and here's the third form.
Same deal.
Now notice incidentally that they had a lot of sample in this one.
So a lot of it had zero transmittance though Cah peaks,
uh,
didn't go all the way.
It did,
weren't sharp at the bottom because they just got cut off.
No light got through the sample.
Okay?
Now if we look at the fingerprint region,
there's forums.
See there's form a and here and here is their,
the peaks.
Here's forum B.
Now what you look for in order to,
if you're going to dispute a patent is,
is the guy who is violating your patent making your compound,
right?
So you try to find peaks in here that are characteristic of your compound and
see whether there's some of that in what the other guy's trying to sell.
Okay,
so you look around here and try to figure out where in this forest of things can
we find a peak,
even if we have no idea what the normal mode is that we'll be able to
distinguish.
And it turns out that those peaks listed below there in green,
a blue and red are ones that occur in,
in,
in the corresponding form and not in the others.
And in particular those peaks there,
the six 65 and the six 75 are very good for distinguishing be an AE,
right?
So there was a patent dispute that involved can one detect 5% of the B,
the six 75 in the presence of 95% of the unprotected one,
in which case they would be violating the patent on B if there were 5% of it
there.
So this is uh,
the,
the legal world and I are being involved in it now.
So we've seen here spectroscopy used both for structure but also for dynamics,
how things are moving.
Right?
And we saw it first in electronic spectrum where we saw the electron slashing up
and down at a rate that had to do with the difference in energy of the two
orbitals that are involved.
We've just seen vibrational and we're going on to nuclear magnetic resonance,
which is at a much lower frequency radio frequencies and involves magnetism,
which we haven't discussed yet.
And it involves precession,
which we haven't discussed yet,
but there are problems on the chem one 20 watt five webpage that will help you
understand what's involved in procession.
Now here's a young Michael Farah Day.
We showed this picture last year and he was a chemist,
remember?
And he discovered benzene in illuminating gas.
We talked about that last semester,
but that's not all he discovered.
He also discovered magnetic induction and he invented the idea of magnetic and
electric fields.
He thought they were real.
They were real little filaments there for these lines of force and the idea that
you can get magnetism from electric,
current and electricity from changing magnetism,
so that's generated generators and so on.
If you're interested in seeing things about that.
Here's a website at Florida State University magnet lab that tells you things
about Faraday and that and 30 years later,
then Maxwell who knew math,
which Ferriday didn't build these into the comprehensive theory of light and
electromagnetism.
Now precession is involved and you've seen precession before.
Here's a,
here's a
a top and remember the amazing thing about this is that if you put it on here,
it doesn't fall down.
Oops.
It does,
right?
It stay standing up and that's an amazing thing,
If it,
if it's not spinning,
let me slow it down just a bit and now that's precession.
When it goes around like this,
I remember how I taught.
It goes like that.
The access goes like this,
right?
And of course if it's not spinning,
gravity just makes it fall down.
So why doesn't that fall down?
Why does it fall around rather than falling down right now?
You can see it better if we use something bigger.
So we'll go to a bicycle wheel here
and I think I've got that on the next slide.
Okay.
So we have a bicycle wheel here.
I hang it up on this thing
second.
Whoa,
get it hooked.
Yeah,
there we go.
Okay.
Now here I'm holding it up.
The string is pulling that way,
but its weight if I let go is going to make it fall.
There is no big deal there.
And that shown right?
There's a,
the,
the forest down of gravity at the Red Arrow and up on the string puts a twist on
it,
which makes it move right at the top and left on the bottom right.
No big deal there.
But it's different as you know,
if it's spinning.
So let me start at spinning here.
Yeah.
And now when I let go,
obviously when I'm holding it,
there is no torque on it.
But if I let go,
it falls around rather than falling down.
Now people talk about vectors and right hand rules,
but why not a left hand rule?
I wonder and so on.
But it's something else to really understand why this is doing,
why there's preset precession in a situation like this.
So normally it would just fall down.
But if it's spinning,
it falls around,
right?
And Feinman in his lectures said something interesting about this.
He said,
many simple things can be deduced mathematically more rapidly,
then they can be really understood.
And a fundamental or simple sense,
the procession of a top looks like some kind of miracle involving right angles
and circles and twists and right hand screws.
What we should do is understand it in a more physical way.
Why does it move around instead of falling down?
Okay?
So that's what we're gonna do here.
And it turns out to have to do with phase again,
and the difference between force and velocity.
So let's think about this.
Uh,
let's take a point on the,
on the rim of this and say,
uh,
notice that there's going to be a torque from this going,
wanting to go down here and being held up here,
right?
And that's transmitted through the spokes to the rim.
So everything above the center feels of force to your right and everything below
the center feels the force to your left.
When I let go,
everybody with me on that.
Okay,
so let's take a point on the rim here.
It feels no force at all cause it's,
it's moving neither right in there,
left,
right as it goes up,
it gets more and more forced to the right.
Everybody with me,
still more forced to the right,
more forced to the right now less force to the right,
less zero.
And now that feels the force to the left,
right as I let go.
Okay?
So we can make a plot of the force as a function of position on the rim.
So if it's in that,
in the picture on the screen here,
when it's above the forces to the right below,
it's to the left.
And this is what the forest should look like,
right when it's in the front or in the back,
there is no force.
One is above.
There's a force to the,
uh,
to the right and when it's below,
there's a force to the left.
Okay.
Now I'm going to ask you a different question.
Where is the velocity to the right fastest?
Where's the force to the right?
Fastest.
Largest force.
At what position?
On the rim.
That's the top right.
So it'll move the furthest it goes.
The fastest one I let go.
It goes much slower here.
Okay,
that's fine.
Now I'm asking a different question.
Where is the velocity fastest to the right?
Well,
let's start here.
It's beginning to feel a little bit of force to the right,
but if it's rotating,
it's still feeling forced to the right more and more and more and more forced to
the right,
more forced to the right maximum force to the right and all.
Now less and less and less and less and less and less and less and less until it
gets to zero.
But all this time,
during this half rotation,
that point that I'm holding is feeling forced to the right.
And what does that mean?
It's accelerating to the right.
Everybody with me on this.
So where is its velocity maximum to the right?
Suppose I start pushing uh,
uh,
somebody on a bicycle and I keep pushing and pushing his beginning.
I don't push very hard.
Then I push real hard and then I don't push very hard.
And finally I let go.
Where are they moving?
Fastest assuming no friction and so on.
At the very end,
all the time I'm pushing,
I'm accelerating it.
So where is the velocity fastest on this?
To the right.
Tell me when I get there there.
And that's exactly what it does.
When it moves like this and then it,
then it's being slowed down,
right?
Cause you're pushing to the left and here it's got zero velocity.
You've canceled it right?
And now it starts moving to the left and reaches its maximum velocity to the
left here.
Then it starts slowing down again and has zero velocity to the left,
to the right,
left or right here.
And that it has a mess.
So it moves like this.
Isn't that neat?
So it's the difference between force and velocity.
That velocity,
you have to integrate fours right over the time that's involved.
So if you look at the where,
where,
where is the velocity maximum?
It's going to be 90 degrees after the Veloce,
after the forces maximum.
So it's going to be the maximum velocity when it's in front,
right?
Velocity to the right.
And as it keeps going,
it's,
it then slows down and it has its maximum velocity to the left at the bottom,
and then it comes back up.
So there's this 90 degree phase lag between the periodic force and the velocity,
and that's why it falls around.
Okay?
So the velocities look like that.
So there's a 90 degree phase lag and it falls around rather than falling down.
Now you've heard of nuclear spin.
Okay.
So these protons,
ones that have an odd atomic weight,
right?
Uh,
either a,
an odd number or an odd wait.
Uh,
we know that they spend,
and the reason we know they spin is that when they're in a magnetic field,
they've precess.
And how do we know that there,
when you put the force on them,
obviously if there's no force,
this doesn't precess it's when you try to twist it.
So if this is a magnet that spinning,
right,
and you put it in a magnet netic field that tries to twist it,
then it goes around and precesses,
right?
So that's what,
that's how you know that these nuclei are magnetic hydrogen,
fluorine and phosphorous.
Those are the common isotopes.
But for carbon and oxygen,
they're uncommon isotopes.
So,
and this is how,
how,
how fast they,
they precess in a,
in a magnetic field,
they precessed like this,
right?
And you could measure the frequency of their going round and round.
And we'll mention that in just a second.
And if the field happens to be 23 and a half kilo gas,
which is not an uncommon field,
then protons go around the fastest,
100 billion times a second,
right?
Fluorine is almost as fast but phosphorus,
carbon,
oxygen or less fast.
So that just to give you a Connecticut public radio broadcasts at 90.5
megahertz,
right?
And WCBS is that 0.88 Megahertz,
eight 80 Kilo Hertz,
right?
So these are radio frequencies.
Now the electron also spins,
but it's way off scale up at the top 66,000 megahertz.
It's a much more powerful magnet than the nuclei,
okay,
so a megahertz multiplied by three and times 10 to the minus fifth is wave
numbers.
Remember in the,
in Isr,
we talked about frequencies in wave numbers,
right?
How many waves in a centimeter?
But this is that the radio frequencies are very,
very,
very slow compared to that,
right?
10 to the minus fifth slower,
or you can also talk about it in degrees Kelvin,
right?
And the 100 megahertz.
Then where the Proton resonates in this frequency is equivalent to 0.01 Kelvin.
And the thing that it's quantized so that the direction of the magnetic field is
either more or less with the applied field or more or less against the applied
field.
But it's not like a compass.
It's not like it can at any angle in different energies.
For each angle,
you can either have this or that.
That's quantification of spin.
Actually quantum mechanics as much easier to do with spin because you can only
have two values were for position or energy.
You could in principle have any value,
right?
Okay.
So,
uh,
the,
the equilibrium ratio of the up to down is 1.003.
So that means that in it there's an x.
If you have 200,000 nuclei,
right?
There are three more pointing up in the favorable direction than pointing down.
It's really,
really wimpy the Boltzmann factor,
the energy difference between those.
Okay.
Then,
oh,
17 occurs at 6% in natural abundance and see 13 at 1%.
But these others like protons are 99.98% and only 0.02% deuterium.
Okay?
Now this is a really neat concept,
the rotating frame.
Uh,
and uh,
let,
let me do this and then I'll let you go because it's holiday coming up.
Okay?
So,
uh,
so there's the applied magnetic field and we remember we said that the,
that the nuclear field,
the axis about which it's spinning can either be more or less up or more or less
down,
but at a particular angle.
So suppose like it's,
it's like that and it precesses because it's spinning and the rate of precession
in that field we just talked about is a 100 megahertz,
right?
That's how fast it goes around.
Okay.
So that noticed that that precessing proton has a constant vertical field,
right?
That doesn't change.
Is it?
Presents is the vertical component,
but the horizontal compound component goes around like that.
Right?
And that looks neat because if that's going around a hundred megahertz,
right?
That's going to be like an antenna and it'll generate light that's coming out.
It's like the vibration of Cio,
right?
Charge going back and forth.
You see it going back and forth as it is like that.
So it looks like we might be able to detect that broadcasting.
Uh,
so will it generate a hundred megahertz radio frequency signal?
No,
it would if you just had one proton.
But of course you have a mole of protons,
or at least a milimole or something of protons,
right?
And so some will be here,
some will be here,
someone will be here.
So we'll be here.
And if you look at the horizontal component,
although the vertical components all add the horizontal components,
components that are changing in time,
cancel everybody see that?
So you don't get any net signal coming out.
Okay?
So the horizontal fields cancel and uh,
and there's a,
but there's a trick that allows you to do it.
And that is,
suppose that,
that instead of us sitting here and watching them precess suppose we orbit
around them at a 100 megahertz,
we would certainly get dizzy,
right?
If we went around 100 megahertz.
But what would a proton look like if we were going around it at 100 megahertz
and it's going around at 100 megahertz?
It would look like it's standing still.
So that makes it much easier to solve the problems,
to work in a rotating frame so that they're not moving around from our point of
view at a hundred megahertz,
they're just standing still.
So we look at these and they're just standing still.
Okay.
Now in our as if there were no applied field,
okay,
now,
now we take a very weak magnetic field that we generate a radiofrequency field
that's horizontal in our frame.
It's horizontal pointing out that way.
Now,
of course,
in truth it's going around at 100 megahertz,
right?
But from our point of view,
it's just sitting there and from our point of view,
there is no applied field because are going around canceled that.
Okay,
so what will the,
what will those protons do is we look at them,
they'll precess around that field,
right?
You see what I'm saying?
From our point of view,
they'll just be this one week,
little magnetic field,
and it'll appear in this,
in a constant position relative to us because we're whipping around so fast.
And so these things will precess around that.
Right?
But they now they make all different angles because they're not quantized with
respect to that when they're quantized with respect to the vertical field.
So they'll precess like that.
That particular one would go and all the others would go processing at the same
rate.
Okay?
So that's about 0.1 megahertz rather than a hundred megahertz.
So this is a thousand times weaker field,
okay?
But we,
how long do we do it?
How long do we put this field on?
Just long enough to make them go 90 degrees
like that.
So now they're pointing out towards us like this,
right?
But in truth,
they're not statically pointing out toward us.
They're going around at a hundred megahertz because we're going around at 100
megahertz,
right?
And now there's a net field,
That's oscillating in time.
If we go back and stop and take ourselves back to the laboratory and not spin
around like that or orbit like that,
we see them,
this whole set going around like that.
So if we put in this thing called a 90 degree pulse,
now we can hear these things broadcasting and what will they tell us?
They'll tell us how strong the torque is.
I didn't do that here,
but let me,
let me do it.
Yeah.
Now,
if this is a magnet,
I can twist it by putting a magnet field perpendicular to it.
Right now.
Suppose I made the field that's perpendicular,
stronger,
right?
The twist that harder.
So that's how fast it's processing.
What happens if I try to make it go put a foot,
put this wrench on.
It's going to go faster or slower if I hang it on here.
Okay.
Faster or slower?
Let me speed it up again here.
Yeah.
Incidentally,
that's another question.
If I go faster,
if I make it spin faster,
will it precess faster or slower?
It precesses only because it's spinning,
right?
If it weren't spinning,
it wouldn't precess so suppose suppose I spend faster,
does it go faster or slower?
Faster should go faster.
No,
because the amount of time that's involved,
you in here that we're pushing is shorter if it's spinning faster.
So in fact it goes slower.
Isn't that neat?
And now if I twist harder,
it goes faster.
See how it's going faster now and then it slows down.
If I take that off,
it's not an ideal demonstration,
I grant you,
but you know the,
the heart,
the,
uh,
if in fact it goes slower.
If you,
if you,
pardon me,
it goes faster if you put more torque on and it's spinning at the same rate.
So that's what these problems are for you to,
to think about.
So just to finish in a second here,
so,
uh,
so we went into the rotating frame long enough to get them to 90 degrees and now
we go back and now we see a signal coming out at a hundred megahertz.
So that's how you do the Nmr experiment.
They go like that,
and that's the signal,
you see?
So it's a hundred megahertz in the laboratory frame until they relax and go back
to where they started.
Right.
Then the signal goes away.
Okay.
So that's what we're going to talk about.
Some more.
Have a good break.